Speaker 1: Let's go to Jason from Huntsville,
Alabama.
Jason, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: He.
Oh, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Hey, I was going to go.
All right.
I know we have a queue of callers, so I'll
try to keep it short like one or two questions,
one of the things I was rattling kind of thinking
about was how Congress just usually tends
to have this kind of goes back to Neil deGrasse
Tyson, how we talked about when he was a kid
he would look up to like leaders and powerful,
I guess, inspiring leaders.
And when he looks at Congress, all he sees
is businessman, businessman, politician, law
businessman and businessman.
Like, where?
Where are the scientists, where the engineers?
And I thought, wouldn't it be better?
I'm sorry otherwise, if there were more a
greater diversity of professions, especially
if there were more scientists and engineers
in office, or also architects, doctors, just
civil engineers, just a great diversity of
multiple professions and perspectives in Congress.
Speaker 1: Yes, I've spoken about this many
times before.
Absolutely, we should be having people representing
us from a much wider range of industries and
professions, for sure.
No doubt about it's hard to argue against
that.
Speaker 2: And yeah, that's because I remember
Bill Nye the Science Guy, would I used to
believe it would be a lot better if only like
if there were a lot more scientists and engineers?
Yeah, or in office.
But he would come along and say if there were
only scientists and engineers in office, that
wouldn't improve anything, because that's
still one perspectives, for sure.
Another quick question.
I thought a lot about, of course, Donald Trump
is still relevant.
People are still talking about him.
It would if it would be more appropriate that
if he ever gets held accountable instead of
being jailed for prison, which is unlikely.
Wouldn't it be more appropriate if he was
submitted for psychological evaluation and
admitted into a mental institution?
Speaker 1: Sure.
I mean, here, you know, it's fine.
Yes, it would make sense to figure out once
and for all what is going on with this with
his mental state.
But you know, it's very difficult, particularly
for four people in his position to forcibly
submit to that.
So I don't know that it's worth spending too
too much time thinking and talking about it
because it's it's not going to happen, you
know, that's unfortunate.
Speaker 2: Wouldn't there be a chance that
it could be court ordered?
Speaker 1: Yes, there's obviously a chance,
but I can't imagine any path towards that
being what happens?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Yeah, well, it's it's a it's a thought.
All right, well, how do I?
I'll hand over my call to the next.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thank you so much for the call.
I very much appreciate it and a lot of different
things on people's minds today, which is which
is great.
Let's go next to Vitaly from Israel.
Vitaly, you are on the air.
Speaker 2: Hello.
I wasn't expecting to be selected.
Wow.
Well, here we are.
Thanks, anyway.
Yeah.
And I have more geopolitical question.
It's pretends to perhaps the United States
now with the tensions in the Ukraine, and
we possibly are going through into a confrontation
between NATO's United States, Ukraine and
Russia.
In your mind?
Well, what do you think like the consensus
in the United States would be if like a public
opinion, if it would be escalating to a war?
Speaker 1: You're saying like a boots on the
ground type war,
Speaker 2: any kind of armed conflict?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Vitaly, if you can please turn off notifications
in discord because we can hear every time
that it blinks and it's very, very distracting
to the audience.
My belief is that by a small margin, the you,
the American people would be in favor of the
U.S. and NATO coming to the defense of Ukraine
against hostilities from Russia by a small
margin.
That's my prediction about what would happen.
Speaker 2: OK, thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, Vitaly, from Israel.
There we go.
Yeah.
Always remember to turn off Discord notifications.
Very, very important.